[Music]
that's gonna do it mango not using the
cliff to its full potential and zayn
taking it three two
i remember when i lost last year's big
house there's a picture of me like just
super defeated after because then it's
like oh maybe i do suck maybe like
maybe maybe i don't got anymore maybe i
can't compete in the meta it's kind of a
common thing with mango where it's like
he's so good but there's just like a
couple things that he could clean those
up then it could be entirely different
you're probably wondering mango why did
you tweet that out when i said i just
wanted to go home because i did want to
go home
every set i played up until that i
played like [ __ ] yeah how'd you feel
playing mango oh
you know he's on fire he has like losers
run up like five sets in a row he's just
playing super hot
[Applause]
mango has always hated losing recovering
high again there's armada looking
forward to mix up but
out of shield can he even make it back
no armada's going to slap him oh my god
he did not see the repeat of royal flush
wow 3-1 armada
winning evo 2017 from winners so like my
motivation is like i don't want to feel
that way i don't want to go through all
that again so for me it's just pretty
much losing is my biggest motivation but
as one of the five gods of melee in his
prime mango didn't have to worry about
losing too often now we feel the tension
of armada no but wait a minute
he just comes down from the platform and
gets a grab on the top big house six
going to mako but the last few years
have been different new faces entered
the scene the old gods were retiring and
suddenly mango found himself facing the
possibility that he was well
washed i remember when i lost last
year's big house there's a picture of me
like just super defeated after because
then it's like oh maybe i do suck maybe
like
maybe maybe i don't got it anymore maybe
i can't compete in the meta for a
competitor of mango's caliber the
continuous disappointments throughout
2020 could have meant that he was losing
his touch
does he recover high low what has zane
got
that's gonna do it mango not using the
cliff to its full potential and zayn
taking it 3-2 last off but as mango
himself said losing was just the
motivation he needed and luckily for
mango fans he was about to go on one of
the sickest tournament runs of his
career
[Music]
going into smash summit 11 manga was
facing a number of challenges the
tournament was the first in-person event
since the start of the global pandemic
so there was a lot riding on the result
on top of that mango has never won
summit
he killed himself after oh
wow
and the memory of losing to zayn melee's
number one up-and-comer in the grand
finals of the online smackdown of 10
still stung like if i have a chance to
win an fd game which i did
and i drop it
i don't care what happened before i
dropped it i played ass and i lost it i
could have gone up 2-1 with an fd game
that would have shattered his mental
because he knows he's not supposed to
lose on fd all of a sudden the set is
completely different all of a sudden i'm
feeling myself that's why i said i don't
play well because i dropped these big
moments smash summit 11 looked like
mango's last chance to prove he still
had what it took to be a god
unfortunately things didn't exactly
start out with a bang that might be it
that was chris is in right now mango
with barely a shield he misses a wave
bro he's a mix up away oh living
after qualifying at the top of his group
in pools mango lost his first quarter
finals match against plup and tumbled
straight down into the losers bracket he
wasn't exactly feeling hot going into
the tournament and this loss was a
pretty devastating blow to his
confidence you're probably wondering
mango why did you tweet that out when i
said
i just wanted to go home because i did
want to go home
that
i was done i was so [ __ ] over every
set i played up until that i played like
[ __ ] mango now had to win literally
every match he played against some of
the best players in the world if he
wanted to win the tournament it wasn't
impossible but the odds were heavily
stacked against him manga will likely
crush either of those people because
he's so good against falcon
and
and very good he's probably like one of
the best against marth too
uh and so he has a pretty good ride to
top eight
uh and then it'll get pretty hard pretty
fast but mango wouldn't be mango if he
was just gonna lie down and take it and
any self-respecting smash fan knows that
a loser's bracket mango is a force of
nature oh what a nice read on mangoes
to the full hops coming out oh we're at
the roll hey guys you have to damage
them okay there we go
wow
anybody's game oh reads to roll in
scratching his nose what was that
oh excuse me
mango takes a 3-0 multiple opportunities
mango just looking so strong right now
with this pressure that shield is so
small oh it's going to pop
oh
i think that's going to be it
what a set one more top player gets
mangoed and if that wasn't impressive
enough mango took the run back against
plup and then beat hungrybox in the
loser's finals
oh my goodness somehow
yeah how did you feel playing mango
you know he's on fire he has like losers
run of like five sets in a row he's just
playing super hot it's going to be an
incredible grand finals uh and it's the
way it should be except these are the
two best players in the studio right now
and that's what grand finals should have
there was now only one more opponent
standing between mango in his first
summit win the next god of melee and the
man who bested him last time
zayn
[Music]
winning smash summit 11 wasn't just
about the prestige both mango and zayn
were fighting over the largest cash
prize in competitive smash history not
to mention the fact that their
reputations were at stake zayn's win
would cement his status as the new
greatest player in the world while
mango's loss would validate all his
self-doubts after zayn took the first
two games it seemed like mango was done
for but zane just needs one hit though
his weight dashes are crazy bro
oh no she'll grab for mango
zane's up to uh felt that uh
still available it seemed as if history
was repeating itself except this time it
was all happening in person but mango
was not about to go down without a fight
well right now this is a huge punishment
oh my god we'll be dead here
oh yo
yo he's poking
[Applause]
after the bracket reset both mango and
zane had a chance to catch their breath
before the real battle began one of them
was about to make history okay
zane oh it doesn't exist
same on the board game one put down
[Music]
counter
[Music]
okay wait
this time for sure right delayed back
air ledge yeah all right 2-1 zane fd off
the field mangoes yes he's still going
for it zayn has like almost no shield
we're going to game two oh my goodness
we're going to game
[Music]
after winning smackdown at 11 at 29
years of age mango became the
tournament's oldest champion and he was
damn proud of his achievements
congratulations
mango the match-up was so incredibly
close that it literally came down to one
frame as mew2king explained in his
analysis of the set this one frame
changed the tournament he can't shield
here
now i can shield and zayn being one
frame late here change the tournament
mango won something more than an
important set against zayn or a coveted
championship title he won against
accusations of being washed defeated his
own insecurities and silenced any and
all haters who ever said he wasn't on
the same level as the rest of the gods i
was always like a firm believer in this
but seeing how far i've been here and
doing that i think i might be ready to
call it the goat
nice thing you've ever told me well
you're you're still in this [ __ ] after
everything after this tournament the
doubts can finally be put to rest mango
really is the melee goat
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages